hello and welcome to
another event on the spectators
alternative conference
um we today are going to be looking at a
topic that kate andrews wrote about back
i think we've now left the summer so
back in the summer
and at the time she posed the question
about magic money now when she wrote
this the figures were pretty stark
we had we're looking at a deficit 300
billion
made possible by 200 billion of
quantitative easing
and at the time one senior tory mp as
she created her cutter piece
said we fought the last election saying
there was no money tree
now we say there is one and it's in the
garden of the bank of england
since then the sums have got even more
vast
and we had the chance then add small
measures in his winter economic package
however rishi sunak has indicated that
one day he may have to balance the books
something no one in the country has done
for quite a while now
so to discuss how the current situation
looks
how long it can last and rather the
tories are on cause for a nasty surprise
i'm delighted to be joined by a panel of
kate andrews all for herself
uh liam harrigan who writes for the
telegraph on economics and also the
spectator
and our editor fraser nelson and kate
we'll go to you first uh can you just
give us an update of how the magic money
tree is looking
is it in full bloom so it's still
growing
as you said katie when the cover piece
was written over the summer we had
200 billion pounds worth of quantitative
easing being
pumped now that's gone up to 300 billion
since then we've had an extra
100 billion and also estimates to how
big the uk's deficit will be this year
have also
increased i think the official ones from
the obr are now almost at 400 billion
while some independent estimates have
put it over 400 billion
now we have been told all year that this
is a one-off spending spree that you
should think of it as wartime spending
that this is
not normal behavior that we're not going
to create a structural deficit that is
increasing day-to-day spending
that you then have to tackle down the
road i think the problem we have here
is well it's twofold when when the piece
was written back
in the summer it seemed as if the
governor of the bank of england andrew
bailey was
going to be extremely cautious about not
mixing
up covert emergency spending and
day-to-day spending
um reports that he was making very clear
in fact he made clear
on sacha javid's podcast that he was
happy to fund the treasury to the point
of helping with coronavirus but he
wasn't going to be
subsidizing railways he wasn't going to
be contributing to the green agenda that
that was something that government had
to decide and raise revenue accordingly
but last week we saw the governor make
another intervention and it was
to the tune of rethinking the furlough
scheme specifically the furlough scheme
coming to an end and then
almost immediately we had the chancellor
updating us with the job support package
now that costs a lot less money or is
estimated to cost a lot less money
than the furlough scheme did but i think
it was an indication that perhaps
the bank of england is going to be quite
happy to continue to directly finance
the treasury
for these kova schemes well past 2020
and that raises questions about whether
or not this is a one-off spend or if we
are starting to create a structural
deficit
and uh that's a that's a very different
uh
ball game really because it puts the uk
on much shakier financial ground
now in this discussion we will be taking
questions so if you do have any
questions write them into the zoom
chat function and we'll try and get in
as many as possible
and particularly if you want to uh come
out in defense of the magic money tree
we're ready to hear that
um liam when we're looking at
quantitative easing something you often
hear from troy mps these days is
actually we should all chill out about
borrowing their historically low rates
and you know we might have talked about
a long-term economic plan a while ago
but this is quite a vote because the
circumstances have changed
and so have we so do they have a point
um yeah it's different this time the
most dangerous words in the english
language
everybody wants to believe it's
different this time but of course
it isn't let's just consider where we
are
katie so the ftse 100 is 20
up since uh lockdown in march that's
bull market territory
and even though the uk government has
borrowed 175 billion pounds so far this
year and is heading for a 20
of gdp budget deficit borrowing costs
are actually down
have the laws of economics been
suspended no they haven't the reasons
stock markets are so dangerously bloated
bond markets are so dangerously bloated
with bond prices high which makes yields
low
is because of course quantitative easing
now back in 2009 the global banking
system was on the brink of collapse
there was a justification for
emergency monetary measures
but that post-crisis uh necessity it
should have been used as a crash pad to
sort of restructure our banking system
instead it became a comfort blanket so
the kind of
emergency measure has become medicine
has become like a sort of lifestyle
choice back in 2009 our qe program was
billed as a 50 billion
pound program
egged on by city financiers who wanted
share prices to keep going like the
clappers egged on by governments who
wanted to keep borrowing money
as much as they wanted to uh and keep
bomb prices low with the bank of england
buying
bonds qe rather than 50 billion
it went to 450 billion by the end of
2019 so that's a
nine times bigger than it was uh billed
as
and it's not just the uk of course the
fed is doing this the bank of japan is
doing this
the ecb is doing this but since march
our 450 billion quid of quantitative
easing
has become 745 billion quid
of quantitative easing and where the
government the bank of england is buying
bonds now at twice the rate that it was
during the financial crisis now as you
say much of our media class our
political classes convince themselves
that this will all be fine you know you
get westminster sages
who never really taken any notice of
bond markets saying oh debt service
costs are low
it will all be fine but it will you know
in the end the markets will decide what
the rate of interest is whatever the
bank of england
says and does and that's one of the
cardinal lessons of history
and i'd say and i've written in the
spectator in the past
that i think quantitative easing now is
well past the point where it's actually
counter
productive financial markets have lost
their ability
to correct because of this so they're
taking bigger and bigger risks
central bank bond buying means far too
much money's locked up in zombie cut
companies
that wouldn't survive without
quantitative easing
and that means we're getting low
productivity this distorts basic
economics if you don't get a return on
your savings and you're paid to borrow
with very much through the looking glass
and people often accuse me of
overstating this where's that inflation
you spoke about
they say to me and i suspect that will
come up in this um
uh meeting too and what i say is
look we have seen enormous inflation in
stock prices in bond prices
in property prices but a lot of the qe
money
has stayed inside the bank banking
system the
the commercial banks have given it back
to the central banks
as as reserves so the commercial banks
that were
insolvent look solvent even though
they've relied on quantitative easing
and what i'd say is we're building up
huge debts because of quantitative
easing that will come back
to haunt us and as the final thing
you know we've got interviews now soft
soap interviews from uh
bank of england monetary policy
committee members saying oh it'd be fine
if we
if we yank interest rates into nominal
negative territory interest rates of
course have been in real terms negative
territory
for a long time into nominal negative
territory
look outside of the city of london
outside of the financiers
real world investors they're not not
investing because interest rates
are too high taking interest rates
negative aren't going to make
people build more factories and employ
more people out there in the real world
in the 90 percent of the
economy that isn't financial services in
fact this kind of extreme monetary
policy is
really spooking most run-of-the-mill
business owners and business leaders
and i think if we go to negative
interest rates which will be solely
duplicate financial markets solely so
everyone can keep dancing
then that will mean that the real world
investors leaving
more money on the table we should be
implementing a monetary retreat we
should be trying to cool
financial markets rather than keep
stoking them up and the prerequisite of
that
is having the debate the argument that
we're having today in saying that even
though
everybody's got a vested interest in
wanting this thing to continue
in the end it has to end fraser
liam mentions that many are quick to say
well we haven't seen that change in
inflation
and can you see any positives in the
current magic money situation
yeah you bet and um it's like 10 years
ago i would have been lining up with
liam
absolutely i made the same predictions
as he did about quantitative easing
basically look saying you can't get
money for nothing it will all end in
tears
well you know what it didn't end in
tears i
made predictions about how inflation
would be and at some point or another
rising away he said we've seen hardly
any inflation
and it has led me to begin to do
something i don't
very often do which is to change my mind
and i'm not now saying that i'm now
basically
going to advocate the government keeps
spending like a drunken keynesians
um all day around um i instinctively
feel
that something is going wrong when the
government's solution to every problem
is suspend and borrow money
but i find it harder now to argue with
those who say to me
look you guys said 10 years ago the qe
lent a disaster it didn't you've been
saying for 10 years
the interest rates are going to go back
to normal they haven't
and in fact the whole of austerity was
based on this assumption
that if governments didn't balance their
books then the bond markets would come
back and punish us in other words
if governments didn't manage to and get
their deficits under control
the cost of borrowing would be really
high it would be like five percent
seven percent and we would be punished
in a way that italy was being punished
ten years ago but let's just have a look
at what's happened recently so
i think we can all agree that in the
last 10 years
um the british government has not
particularly behaved itself when
it came to debt we entered the last
decade with debt
of about one trillion pounds now we're
at debt of about
two trillion pounds we've national
double the national debt over that
period
then we hit a genuine crisis in
coronavirus
we see economies collapse we see the
biggest contraction in economic growth
that any of us will ever live through
we've seen
and landlords unable to collect rent
we've seen shops unable to collect
customers in a massive shock
to the financial system and what
happened were they living on the edge
did they collapse no
they all the banking system managed to
get through this pretty well
because they had been stress tested ever
since the last tech
crash the regulators were coming and
they were saying okay
let's see make sure you guys have got
enough capital so if there is a
recession
if these following that bad things do
happen that you're ready to withstand
the shock
all of those stress tests seem to have
worked we haven't seen any failed banks
and we've seen the most incredible
financial upheaval that anybody can
remember
we've also seen the british government
borrow i think
something like 130 billion extra pounds
in borrowing
and it seems the markets are quite happy
to do that right now
the rate of interest is in zero is zero
point two percent now
i know what um liam and kate will be
itching to say yes
the interest rates are only so low
because the um the bank of england is
printing money right now it's
artificially depressing the guilt
markets these aren't real market rates
you wait to see what happens when they
start printing money and yes i accept
all those arguments they could well be
true
i'm just saying that right now the thing
that hasn't happened is the financial
domino has not fallen over
a decade's worth of debt and pretty high
spending
has not rebounded in britain right now
so you have to ask
has something changed now i tell you
what has been niggling away at my mind
and i'll be interested to know
um how liam and kate's um explain this
you can look at the um the interest
rates not just for the last few years we
all know it's been crazy these last few
years
but we look back over decades you can
see a steady decline
in global interest rates heading towards
zero
now they're going beneath zero we're
getting negative real interest rates
were being paid to borrow and yes it
sounds crazy
but it's not so crazy that it has led to
economies
toppling over so might it just be
that we're in a new monetary era that
there is such a thing
as new monetary theory they could be
written off by conservatives as the
magic monetary
but right now there's a glut of asian
savings there's a huge amount of money
looking for a home
and we're living through a period we're
simply the safe keeping of money
the knowledge that you'll return the
money that you lent
is enough for you to actually be paid to
keep that money it sounds crazy
but it's not happening in enough
countries for it
to be true so this is why i think
there's been a fundamental change in the
monetary weather
now things might i know i can also hear
liam thinking ah fraser you're saying
this time is different this is the
refrain that we've heard throughout
history before
every single time things go pop now
that's right
but we also ought to keep our minds open
i think to the idea of at this time it
really
is different and there's something here
that the classic economists that the um
the bond vigilantes
haven't quite worked out and perhaps
boris johnson's on to something
when he actually says that yes you can
borrow because the markets do
want to lend and with interest rates so
low it would be frankly rude
not to now i'm going to go to the other
panel of this for their response to that
phrase but just quickly first so you're
in rishi sunak's shoes and you're
looking ahead
do you think that responsibly he can
shake that money tree for a little bit
longer
oh you bet i mean there's i wouldn't be
surprised
because the bank of england does another
100 billion of money printing he can
keep
shaking it so it can keep producing this
fruit the question is whether it will
all turn to ashes
at some point and and if i were issues i
would be thinking to myself like you
simply cannot run an economy
on the gamble and it is a very big
gamble that we're in
this new monetary era what sahaja yoga
is predecessor called the low
prolonged era and because we don't
the thing is the conventional economics
does not explain
the monetary situation that we find in
ourselves in right now
the old textbooks would tell you as liam
and kate will tell you that
we ought to be paid a big financial
price for this now the old laws of
gravity might reassert themselves
at any point so if i were if you seem
like i would absolutely be trying to get
s reconcile taxes and spending to a
level where they ought to be right now
but i can see why rishi sunak why sasha
javid
why even chancellor and liam halligan
would struggle to win this argument
against the number 10 that would
basically say look you guys have been
saying this for 10 years
it hasn't happened the market's willing
to lend us money
so let's just keep doing it because
right now we need to build these roads
and sasha javid by the way he's no um
he's no lefty economist he's a former
financier and he was saying look
on a basic financial um prognosis here
if you can borrow money at 0.1 percent
in a project that will give you
a two percent return then you do it you
cover your costs you do it
and for as long as people are willing to
lend money to the government at this low
levels
it makes economic sense to invest that
money on projects
that will deliver a positive return on
that borrowing
kate let's go to you first what do you
say in response to fraser are there laws
of gravity changing on this
gosh a lot um i have a lot to say
but i i guess to come back very quickly
on the point that fraser just raised
about uh the former chancellor
um it's one thing to say look we can
borrow this money
so we can spend this money and let's
invest it i think the follow-up to that
would always be is it a good investment
you're still using resources and are
they best spent in in the public sector
as opposed to the private sector is it
really the case that
this is going to create the money create
the jobs that you think it is
very often government is bad at picking
these projects so just because you can
spend money in a moment doesn't
necessarily
mean that you should but to the broader
point that fraser raised are we just in
this new monetary era i mean
possibly i wouldn't rule anything out
these days it's impossible to say
really where we're going and whether or
not the uk government and indeed
governments around the world will be
punished for printing this money and
borrowing
at such high rates but people often
point to japan to say look you can do qe
successfully it's fine to have negative
interest rates
but you can't just compare these
countries monetary policies without
looking with
what's happening on on beneath the
surface i should say um
japan is thought to be a real exception
here and that actually the savings and
the money
is in the japanese economy that private
individuals
save so much more compared to here in
the uk
that if somebody ever said you know what
we're gonna
we're gonna build them we need to find
this money that it actually is there
in the japanese economy and the way that
it really isn't in the uk
i think another issue you have is that
it may well be that the uk isn't
punished this time
but as i said in the beginning our
financial situation is becoming
increasingly
shaky the office for budget
responsibility estimated that
without coronavirus in the next 50 years
the uk's debt to gdp ratio
ratio would be a staggering 275 percent
that's without a pandemic without
emergency spending for
decades now the uk government has been
spending money it doesn't have it's been
making promises
around pensions and health care uh and
and
and many other giveaways in society
that it really can't afford and i think
that
coven 19 may not be the breaking point
and i don't know what the breaking point
will be i don't think anybody on this
panel could possibly say
but one of the major issues and what i'm
really nervous about isn't that
printing money to help tackle cove in 19
is the problem but the fact that we were
on such
shaky ground to begin with at some point
there's going to be nowhere else to go
and it might not be this pandemic
we might just about get through but i
think it's notable
that our debt finance spending is higher
than it is in italy
or greece or spain britain's having to
borrow more than almost
any other developed country so all the
western countries may look quite ugly at
the end of this
but if britain looks ugliest that's
going to be
quite a serious problem not not not just
in in the short term but in the medium
and long term for paying off
this debt eventually you need to inspire
confidence you need to be the country
where people want to invest and
britain at the moment isn't looking as
good as it could
liam what do you say to that and what
fraser was talking about i mean
as he says we've been expecting us all
told this might be coming for some time
so is it enough to just say just wait a
bit longer and then i'll be right
um i mean what i'd say about inflation
since 2009 is that we have had inflation
we've had really big inflation in asset
markets in bond prices in stock prices
in property prices
it's almost as if the the way we measure
inflation around the western world
for nerds who me like me who follow
things like cpi baskets
it's almost as if the measurement has
been deliberately altered in order to
make sure that things
prices are going up aren't actually
included in the headline measures
we've also had since 2008 nine the kind
of one-off impact of much much
cheaper chinese imports china
imports from china and chinese exports
now are much getting much more expensive
and that's a one-off
uh historic impact that helped us to
keep inflation low that
drops out of the numbers um
also we should we should remember what
happened with a lot of this quantitative
easing money after the financial crisis
as i as i explained briefly in my
opening remarks
uh the bank of england bought bonds off
market participants and those often
investment banks and other financial
services companies and they then
returned the proceeds to the central
bank in order to bolster their balance
sheets as reserves
and a lot of our bank restructuring
wasn't actually when the banks issued
more
more equity uh which is a more
conventional
way of banks uh restructuring and facing
the music
they literally used money that the bank
of england had given them that was
created from nowhere
and that money is still held on reserve
in the central bank
so for the students of economics you've
got like friedman's
v the velocity of circulation has been
on the floor for the last 10 years and
that's a big reason why we haven't had
inflation
uh you know measured in a conventional
sense but if the bank's banking system
does start lending again
as the government wants it to then that
that inflationary toothpaste
will come out of the tube and you won't
be able to get it back in
it's you know it's it's it's difficult
to
um make these arguments in a sort of
political forum because they are
quite technical arguments but many
people in financial markets
understand them and let's not and let's
not
think that the austerity that we did
practice uh between 2010 and
2018 didn't help us to ride the
financial
waves if you like yeah phrase is
completely right that we went from like
800
billion of borrowing when osborne came
in national debt
to over 2 trillion now but we did
show that the uk on a day to day on a
year-to-year basis could broadly live
within its means
and and kate anderson is right it is
currency markets are an ugly contest
we're going to make sure we're not the
ugliest baby and just because everyone
else is doing something doesn't mean
it's okay
if you're doing it more than others now
the you the way the uk economy is
structured let's get down to the brass
tax here
we are a globally oriented
service-driven
gig economy uh
country uh with a huge emphasis on
social interaction and cultural assets
and all the rest of it
we with london as the global hub we have
been hit by covid
much much more than almost any other
major economy in the world
and our borrowing is really a lot more
uh
hyped up in the last three to four
months than other economies
in the world so we are particularly
vulnerable we also have within our
establishment if you like within
politicians and people even at the bank
of england i've talked to
over the years you know they don't quite
get that sterling isn't a reserve
currency anymore if you're
if you're america you can just about
kind of do this that's the exorbitant
privilege
of being able to print hard currency
which wound
the gall up so much and is a big
motivation for the single currency by
the way of the sort of moneyists
of the 60s and the 70s but we are not a
reserve currency
and we have a stonking trade deficit and
no number of liz
trust is doing a good job but no number
of free trade agreements around the
world is going to
mean that our trade deficit suddenly
disappears
and if we start getting if our political
class starts
you know carries on with this kind of
language that it's all fine
then currency markets are going to
notice that i mean i
read the glasgow herald often fraser
will be pleased to know
and um yeah there's a there's a senior
politician from the smp in there just
this morning a former aide to alex
salmond
i mean what he says is the state
literally creates money
it does not need our money the idea that
the state needs to raise
taxes this guy said in order to spend
is simply not correct i mean that's
we're going down this rabbit hole
of of intellectual uh nonsensical
statements
and we have to realize that yeah we've
been getting away for this
for a while during a period when we've
been controlling our spending and being
responsible
and the the whole kind of thrust of the
political debate is about bringing our
spending under control
and our very broad and deep financial
markets have been able to
you know understand and get their minds
around a situation where the bank of
england owns
a third of all outstanding government
debt in this country which it does
but what is unsustainable in the end
will not be sustained
and that's an easy thing to say but it's
it's a truth that
it's very hard it's very hard to deny
you
can't keep on doing this stuff and of
course
everyone will want to pretend you you
can and any number of economists will
line up and be paid to show you the
graphs that prove you can do this
but it just doesn't pass the common
sense sniff test
and in the end financial fundamentals
will prevail
however much politicians talk and
however much central bankers show you
spreadsheets
saying otherwise and a country like the
uk that is so
exposed to these coveted lockdowns and
our economy our hyper global
hyper service driven hyper-connected
economy
is really exposed we should be kind of
proud of that in one sense
but we should be mindful of it in the
other and so i think
unfortunately and i don't say this
lightly i think the uk
is uniquely exposed in this ugly baby
competition
going forward fraser let's talk about
that ugly baby competition around the
world
and how are we comparing at the moment
are we the ugliest
uh other countries are shaking their
magic money tree
uh any looking pretty that's good
there's no ugly babies on this call
katie come on
well we'll look around the world
actually you can see the shaking of the
magic money tree is now an olympic sport
i mean
the brits are good at it but others are
also just as good
i i mean we might say look at this same
look at this basket case economy of ours
we've now got
a massive deficit it's um it's something
like
um i think it's 18 of gdp deficit right
now
but that is while huge and historic and
by the way for scotland it's closer to
25
and so good luck to an independent
scotland financing that in an open
market
but in america it's um it's 15 in japan
it's 11 percent in canada it's thirteen
percent in singapore
is fourteen percent these massive
deficits are being run up
everywhere absolutely everywhere right
now
in fact the only um economy which is
behaving itself is the chinese one and
they've got a deficit closer to four to
five percent and they actually look like
being one of the few economies in the
world that will grow
over the course of this year having
covered so fast from the virus
so we ought to bear in mind that we're
discussing here not a kind of
a crazy theory cooked up by spencer of
people in number 10.
this is the standard way in which large
governments are borrowing
and governments with the central bank
are using the central bank to print
money
so yes the bank of england is printing
money but so is the ecb
so is it japan japan's national banks or
the swedish national bank
the same tactics same devices are being
used
everywhere and they are so far
working so we should put this in context
this isn't something of this isn't
britain taking leave of its senses
this is britain walking pretty much in
lockstep
with other major economies in the world
right now
now obviously i'm not sure if you look
around the world there actually is a
country
with a bigger uh deficit gdp ratio than
britain and i think our 18 19 percent
might be at the very top but is not so
far away from from other countries
so again this normally i would be very
critical of the government my instinct
is to say look you you simply can't
i mean of course we know we have to do
covet spending we know
but and i do get quite disconcerted when
um
when matt hancock does seem to sail for
example a few days ago he was saying
of the care homes don't worry we've
bought an ipad for every resident member
of the care homes now that's
you know okay not the most expensive
thing in the world but it was like a gut
reaction
something's going wrong let's spend lots
of money
let's continue with hs2 an incredibly
expensive project which is absolutely no
chance
of returning the capital in its
investments
and i increase in deficits probably
only about half of it is directly
related to cobit the rest will be
other things that the government is just
letting rip over this general time so
that's why i think rishi tsunak will
have a difficult path if he does intend
to plot his way back to to fiscal
balance
um but right now i have to say but the
markets the world the investments of the
world
are looking like the stock mark the
stock markets are not doing brilliantly
right now i mean they've recovered to
you know pretty much where they were
and pretty crash in america they've been
better in britain a little bit worse
but they're still looking relatively
shaky and investors still looking for
security that security still comes from
lending to governments
and if you want to call that a magic
money tree then fair enough but those
governments can
borrow at a negative rate of interest
rates it's not just britain
this is something which you can do in
countries right
around the world right now now i want to
talk
before this air ends ultimately about
how the chancellor might plot
some route back to eventually balancing
the books send a
signal to the market so they don't get
scoop unspooked
but before we get there i just want to
take a few audience questions
and do selling more you have in on the
chat function
of this now the first one we have here
is would the uk government have been
able to borrow
such staggering sums without
quantitative easing
kate there's no doubt that in order to
get through the copic crisis the bank of
england had to directly finance the
treasury um you know we're talking about
hundreds and hundreds of billions of
pounds that it's needed
to finance this so far um and the bank
of england knew that it's interesting to
look at the boe's response as soon as it
was clear what was about to happen
in the uk and that we were going to be
going into this lockdown
and the bank of england made it very
clear that it would support the treasury
and it also
slashed interest rates from a record
load to an ultra
record low and there were reports that
the bank of england
knew that if interest rates even crept
up towards one percent that the
government would really struggle to
finance its debt
again it speaks to the shaky ground but
also the extent to which
the government is absolutely relying on
the bank of england
when we talk about the magic money tree
we have to be very clear about
where it is i think it was you katie who
mentioned that it's in the bank of
england's
backyard and that the governor has a lot
of control right now and i think that's
why his interjection last week
was so vitally important and it came
right before
the job support scheme which is
estimated to only be about
5 billion pounds over the next six
months but it just
indicates the fact that more firepower
is probably being withheld
and that a lot more money could be spent
if the uk
has more restrictions coming in and
frankly it's hard to see how that
doesn't happen
because we seem to only be going in one
direction almost regardless of
what the infection figures do whether
they're high one day or dipping the next
it seems we're only getting more
restrictions and you know i mean the
government
unless it wanted to do something
extremely painful when it comes to
tax revenue or tax rises which would be
very harmful
to the economy which is on its knees
right now and we said the wrong signal
to business
it it's desperately relying on the bank
of england
let's talk about that fraser because the
bank of england governor last week
and suggested that it was time for a
fairly rethink uh
making it i would say unusual but i
think
the current bank of england governor has
done a few of these things where
it seems to define conventions slightly
in terms of the relationship between the
bank of england
and the chancellor so it made a public
intervention suggesting there could be
more
furlough needed or targeted
interventions do you think that was
a sign that the bank is supportive of
more kiwi are we reading too much into
that or was it actually coordinated with
the treasury potentially
it's an interesting question and right
now
there is not that much love between the
bank of england governor and the prime
minister
it's an open secret that boris johnson
didn't want
em griffith to be the the um the bank of
being governor he wanted andy hold aid
instead
of javed who was then chancellor made a
big fuss about it saying look i'm a
chancellor i get to appoint it
and that was one of the rifts which led
to java's eventual departure
from government so we've got a bank of
england governor
who knows he's there in spite of the
prime minister
not because of him that i don't know
whether that
makes him less inclined to be um helpful
to the government
or not and now perhaps he is also
thinking that
not so much resistance but the
institutional treasury
will right now be trying to win an
argument with government saying look
we can't go on spending like this it's
going to end in tears we need to reign
you in
and number 10 says look who's squealing
right now the markets aren't squealing
so perhaps the bank of england is trying
to let out europe's helpful squeal
um a few months ago there was actually
interestingly enough assassin
did a podcast in his one of his many
post chancellor
and career departures and where he
interviewed
the bank of england governor and was
told
that the whole point of his quantitative
easing is not to support the government
this isn't the bank of england's job the
bank of england's job is to sustain
stability in the economy
not to write endless checks for for
number 10.
now um that was broadly taken to
be a shot across the bows of number 10
thinking look
don't think that you can just keep on
spending like this because we'll turn
off the taps
eventually but mind you that was then
that was about
10 weeks ago and now things have changed
it's getting ready to do
most city economists imagine there's
going to be several
tens of billions more of quantitative
easing that the bank of england is going
to do
um and now it's interesting that the
bank of england's also intervening
and things like the furlough scheme not
really its direct responsibility but
it's chucking his or in the thing is
what we're not hearing
is that is the bank of england really
saying
louder right unfortunately and this has
got to come to an
end the the voice the message that boris
johnson will get
is that yes it is there to give support
for
for quite some time and even in
britain's interest rates of about 0.2
percent
these are still a lot higher than those
of france
germany austria belgium which are a
negative
territory so it doesn't you don't have
to look abroad just
you basically have to look to i don't
know turkey to south africa to malaysia
to find a country which is in serious
trouble with interest rates right now
because the rest of europe certainly
doesn't seem to be what do you make of
it liam
in terms of that relationship because
fraser mentions how that
podcast interview was read in some
quarters i don't think he was
universally welcomed in government it's
fair to say
we all said andrew bailey is speaking
before or due to speak for toriyama
mps bit delayed eventually happened do
you think there's any reason to think
the bank of england
isn't uh prepared to print money for
quite a long time to come
is there any sign that could be kicked
back i think the general
uh trend uh is that
central banks around the world want to
try and pass the buck back to
politicians
to fiscal policy because monetary policy
is so stretched and at such ultra
extreme
levels and there is of course tension
between
um number 10 and thread needle street as
fraser
as fraser said andy haldane was off
obviously a candidate so was you know
suspect
well known to the spectator my co-author
on a book i wrote jerry lyons boris's
former
chief economic adviser when he was mayor
for london um
but again fraser's right in the sense
that you know we are heading for serious
unemployment in this country when i was
a kid
you know ub40 was singing about one in
ten um
um we're looking you know the obr even
is estimating
13 unemployment uh and that was before
the
latest lockdown measures and in that
kind of environment
then there will be an enormous pressure
to
keep looking to the bank of england and
there'll be enormous pressure on the
bank of england
to keep delivering and this is why i
guess i've been
you know i've constantly put my head on
the chopping block
to say that we need to be mindful of
what we're doing because there is going
to be
such pressure to just keep going on
and on and on with this stuff we're
already spending
50 odd billion quid a year on debt
service
costs and that's at ultra low interest
rates if you go from half a percent
to one percent that's 100 increased in
your borrowing costs right there
you know soon a tiny incremental rise in
market interest rates and suddenly we're
spending more on debt interest
than we're spending on schools i mean
that's a
and when you have a sort of political
dynamic
where both major parties are in a kind
of dutch auction of who can outspend the
other one that's when markets start
getting really
concerned that's when financial markets
start reaching for tangible
assets um physical assets or indeed
for the dollar look during the the us
presidential election
you know you're going to have acolytes
of modern monetary theory
isn't interesting that the kind of
economic the academic
uh fashionable theory uh has the same
initials as
magic money tree we're going to be
hearing a lot about you know professors
like stephanie kelton extremely
articulate
people who have you know good academic
credentials who in recent years
she started out with bernie sanders but
have really been
honing these arguments for the political
marketplace in order to make them sound
really credible and those arguments will
jump over the pond to here i just cited
aid to former aides alex sammons senior
smb
figure basically talking complete
nonsense um
about economics and when you have
the labour party saying to the tory
party which they will
oh well you did qe to bail out the
bankers why can't you do qe just to keep
spending more
and more and more and more money so when
even
the more prudent side of politics here
and then the u.s
gets you know engages on this kind of
turf
when the language becomes so extreme
when there doesn't seem to be a grown-up
in the room anymore
that's why when financial markets will
get deeply concerned and
there will be a flight to quality and
i'm afraid again i say this with regret
in that flight to quality
the dollar will benefit and tangible
assets will benefit
um land will benefit but sterling will
not benefit
um and when you have a
real run on a currency that's when you
get a spike in inflation and
interest rates go up whatever the bank
of england says or does um
and that's when you get real you know
that really stymies investment
and it's the poor that suffer most
during this
so i don't really see anything within
our sort of political culture at the
moment within our kind of economic
debate
to stop us getting to a situation where
there is just a complete free-for-all
where
the only reason you're not spending
money uh is because you're
a bad person um and when the political
debate gets to that level which is where
we're headed and we're going to see it
in the states and it will come here
then that's you know that's when you
know history starts repeating
itself and you're sparking crises
now we have a question from gina saying
have any of the political parties find a
better money tree
are there alternatives phrase let's go
to you first on this because
you were probably speaking the most
positively of qe
and i think that i wonder whether it's
made you rethink corbinism for example
it does sound as good as though we are
if we're going back to the various
manifestos we've seen we're mirroring
one
a little bit more these days even even
if it is down to a pandemic
well first of all i wouldn't say i was
speaking positively about qe i i
i my position is that the arguments
against
it that i used 10 years ago and and that
we hear a lot from me and now
are a lot harder to make in the absence
of any
sort of that hard evidence sure i mean
liam can talk to the
to to asset price inflation we do know
that qe does
push up assets um one of the things that
when the latest badge of qe came along i
thought to myself well that would be
come through pretty quickly onto house
prices
and just to shop stock prices as i did
last time around
that is needless to say that exacerbates
inequality
it makes and the whole economy rigged
against those with assets it's a deeply
unfair system whose side effects are
absolutely not
properly discussed what it doesn't do
though
is end or what it hasn't done so far is
then to massive consumer price inflation
as ended to a massive increase in debt
interest
and the kind of a reckoning which you've
had throughout most of our
our economic history i have to say
though
that when i look back on them on
corbinism
and the attacks being used against
corbinism magic monetary let's not
forget
was a theresa may phrase used to
describe the economics of the labour
party
and i remember that this was a great
battle that sanji javed and boros
johnson had during the campaign
there was assassin javed was saying look
we have got to be the party of fiscal
responsibility we need to attack labor
as a spencer party we need to say to
them these guys will spend
spent and you know in your heart there
will be a price to pay
your voter because it does stand to
reason it is common sense
but as soon as they won that election
the tories tore
up they have formally abandoned the
um the balance your budget pledge which
was in the last tory manifesto once they
did that
it became a lot harder to say what was
the big difference
between them between labor and the
tories if jeremy corbyn and john
mcdonnell were in power right now
would they be borrowing just as much as
the
british britain is now and remember
given that our deficit is right now
almost literally the biggest in the
whole wide world
it's hard to think that labor government
would be borrowing that
much more so i do actually think
there ought to be a mini kind of apology
tour of conservatives
to labor economics teams under corbyn
to the effect of saying look we said
there wasn't a magic money tree
we've actually found out but there is
and we intend to use it for the
foreseeable future
we'll take that as the beginning and
liam if we're looking at
we've got a scoop liam if we're looking
at
the political parties so if they've got
better money trees
and do you think there is any do you
look around and see anywhere
any other party doing it better labor
don't say tend to say too much actually
on the economy at the moment ever since
they came up for wealth tax and then
seem to fight about it for a while um
but is it is it more that the
conservatives have taken other parties
money trees and people have
alternatives i think the battle will
become i mean if
if if it does just become um you know
who's got the biggest printing press
um um
then the battle will become and and kate
put her finger on it
um how you actually spend the money the
only kind of
modicum of sort of respectability about
your financial position will then be
ah and you can already hear it in the
political debate but we're spending our
money
we're spending the money on things that
are productive so it'll actually boost
the supply side
and even i would and even i would um put
some store by that argument you know
i've
i've in in my latest book home truth i
wrote that the government should borrow
in order to build social housing um
and then you can use resource accounting
to put those new social homes on the
government's balance sheet
uh rather than spending 25 billion
pounds a year on
on housing benefit to house vulnerable
families lower income families who need
social housing
with private landlords often substandard
unsafe homes not always but but
disproportionately
so you know clearly we are entering a
period in our
economic history where everybody has to
be pretty intellectually agile
with their with their views and that's
only right that's that's the national
debate that's that that's democracy
but there is a danger i would say so
pulling the telescope back and looking
at the big picture there is a danger
when you've got
even very fiscally prudent instinctively
uh prudent political parties political
parties that have
you know their brand is um you know
solid housekeeping
and and growing up economics uh like the
conservative party
um i mean there was quite a lot of um
polling evidence even during the real
tough years of sort of austerity that we
had where osbourne on cameron and you
could never take this away from them
they did
get their spending under control to a
degree even though
there was an awful lot of borrowing
going on on the other side of the
balance sheet
there were lots of polls showing that
was actually quite a popular policy
of course you had interest groups who
were rightly screaming
about lack of money at local government
and lack of money for the justice system
and at the sharp end you know some
social policies were curtailed and those
genuine
human suffering of course but actually
that was broadly popular from a
political point of view
so i mean i think if we look back in
sort of 10 years time on the situation
we're in now
and you know we hear um
all political parties agreeing that yeah
it's different this time you know
who who needs to read the history of the
roman empire or the history of
the weimar republic or you know the
history of mankind frankly because it
happens every
every 100 years or so and we suddenly
believe we've got a better system and we
can
just basically spend as much as we want
and and then there's a collapse because
of that in which ordinary people suffer
most and none of the
people advocating these policies that
the sharp end is going to suffer of
course because
you they'll be they'll be well well
healed then you could really have a
crisis actually
of of of of consent for capitalism you
can have a crisis of consent for the
clever people who are meant to be
looking after us and they've caused like
three mega financial crises in
10 15 or 20 years and so i think an
awful lot
is at stake here if we just carry on
doing this
the logical conclusion is that we're
going to end up in a really big mess
and it won't just be a one-off financial
collapse
when you've had a big financial collapse
so soon after an earlier
financial collapse so soon after the
dot-com
collapse you know then suddenly the the
the
our time on earth as as adults and
opinion formers starts to looks
pretty bad and there will be a political
backlash from that
and it won't be pretty and broadly
liberal-minded people like all of us on
this
call who disagree about most things but
agree fundamentally about
representative democracy and all the
rest of it you can have a lot more
extreme politics if we end up
going down a financial cul-de-sac
because of this policy
and now i just want really about 10
minutes left so if you have any
last-minute questions do you send them
in but otherwise i want to touch on a
few we've got in which is almost
how does rishi see that get us out of
this so i wondered in terms of closing
remarks
i'd be good to hear from each of you
what you think you know you were the
chancellor if you're looking at the fact
and everyone here has agreed
that whether or not this position is
sustainable as chancellor you have to
be responsible and presume it's not what
do you think the step
is to getting to a place where not
balancing the books perhaps but on
at least on the path to it because all
the restrictions with the habits we've
got into
it can seem quite hard to find that
particularly when there seems to be
a general consensus at the moment which
as fraser you were touching on
we would almost be there the outlier of
if we broke it
and who would like to go first i would
um
say that the step rising sunny needs to
take if he wants to do that
is a step next door into number 10
because right now i am under boris
johnson
he the prime minister is you know he
once described his
political philosophy as being uh as cake
as a pro having cake pro
eating it now that is what you do with
deficits
you decide you know when faced with a
choice
of spending as much as a continental
european country
or taxing as little as britain has
historically you want to
do both thinking that the magic money
tree will come in the
middle and his political careers tended
to be defined
by the rejection of choices which
lesser mortals have had to make and and
i think
it will take quite a lot to persuade him
i mean he by the way he's already ruled
out and going back to
what we used to call austerity he ruled
that out in one of his speeches
in addition by the way to ruling out um
vat
tax increases to on income tax increases
his manifesto basically um rules out
raising taxes he's ruled out spending
less uh
so the only thing in the middle of that
is a magic monetary
now once those major decisions have been
taken by the prime minister
the job of a chancellor really is to
keep on finding the money
um i suspect that russia sunk would
quite like it if the conservatives were
talking about the need to balance the
budget
a bit more if it were a discussion held
by a few more voices than the ones
around
this this panel today the problem is
that the tories who used to be so
the most keen on balancing budgets are
now mad keen for brexit
and they don't mind about quite a lot of
borrowing
because it's more important to them that
the bill is written to get the brexit
transition done
so the john redwoods of this world are
basically not
back in formation in the same way that
they were under david cameron
to get the balanced budget and therefore
boris doesn't really face the political
pressure or the economic pressure
to to stop shaking that tree
liam what do you think is there a way to
get on you know
half of the straightener now without uh
losing boris johnson as prime minister
i i agree with i agree with uh the
phrase that a lot of the more hawkish
people their eyes are elsewhere
uh at the moment um i mean i
i'd stress that you know if you look
back to 2009 the uk was
disproportionately impacted because it
was a global banking crisis and we got a
lot of banks
a big financial services industry and
we're similarly disproportionately
impacted by this pandemic because as i
said at the opening
we're a service driven economy an
outward-looking hyper-globalized
um economy i do think it is going to be
difficult for
uh rishi sunak he is a very
financially sophisticated person and i'm
sure
you know he has the same kind of
concerns about
fiscal realism that sajid javid has you
know they're from
similar backgrounds before politics they
were
you know genuinely involved in financial
markets
at a high level and once you've done had
that kind of experience
it never really it never really uh
leaves you
i think we are going to see though a a
continuation
we're going to sort of suck and see
aren't we over the next six months
and hope that we can manage to grow our
way
out of this crisis um uh what i'd really
like to see from the chancellor and i
gave him a little bit of a hard time in
my column at the weekend i'm i'm sure he
was concerned about that
um i'd like to see much more of a of a
vision thing
and this isn't just soaring rhetoric
look
investors real world investors not
financial market investors but real
world investors
they're sitting on a lot of cash because
they're really spooked by what the
political and media class basically is
saying and doing about with monetary
policy
and they think financial markets are
overbloated both bond and stock markets
and
their rights to convince people business
owners business leaders to put their
money
on to work again to build that extra
production to build those factories to
re-employ people
after covid you need to you know keynes
taught us about animal spirits you need
to stir the natural entrepreneurialism
of this country which we have in
spades and is always i think our trump
card in getting our
our kind of skewed over financialized
economy
out of the hole again and again
generation after generation
and i was actually a little bit
disappointed that
there wasn't more of the vision thing
we've had very little about the vision
thing in economics from the prime
minister
and similarly from the chancellor and
this kind of speech making
and steering and leading is really
really important
to signal to investors real world
investors
where we're going to give them a kind of
story a narrative that they can cling on
to
and i actually think it was a tactical
error for
the chancellor to rule out having a
budget now
some people would say oh we there's
enough uncertainty and
other people are saying oh we don't need
a budget because that would have
implications on our brexit negotiations
and all the rest of it
but look we just borrowed 35 billion
pounds in one month right we've borrowed
175 billion
since march we need to to declare
and and and attempt to explain
even in a situation of enormous
uncertainty everyone knows there's huge
uncertainty
but you need to at least have the
difficult discussions within government
and between departments about how we can
get out of this even under the current
circumstances
and assuming the current circumstances
either get better stay the same or get
worse in terms of
lockdown and of course our lockdown
policy will be key
to all of this the fact that he delayed
the budget to me
it looked a bit like when a plc delays
an audit right
it always goes wrong it always leads to
a reduction in the share price it's
always because there's issues you don't
want to face
there's realities that you can't stomach
and i think to delay a budget
it risks signaling to the markets that
the chancellor and the prime minister
can't handle having these really really
difficult discussions
about fiscal policy and that is a
concern to me because once you stop
having those discussions
and the big players in government put
their heads down
a hole like ostriches that's when
markets start getting
concerned so i hope it isn't but i hope
we aren't looking back in
in six months thinking that delaying
that budget ruling out a budget or even
a
serious fiscal update uh this autumn
uh i hope that doesn't turn out to be a
big error
thanks liam and kate you get the final
word what is the
best path out of this look i don't envy
the chancellor either
as fraser's already touched upon you can
cut spending go for austerity
uh but based on the reporting that
you've done
katie on the internal workings of the
conservative party they don't want to
touch that with a 10-foot pole
the fact that they're pressing on with
hs2 would suggest they really have no
plans to cut spending i don't think
your average member of the public public
would think that scrapping that in
very unpopular project would count as
the traditional
interpretation of austerity uh but there
we go
um the chancellor can raise taxes uh
arguably another form of austerity uh
but he can raise taxes but
that has significant political costs
potentially breaking manifesto promises
as well they're in a very tricky
position you can't go around looking at
who did well
in the age of coronavirus the businesses
in particular that got us through that
adapted that kept us fed
and entertained sitting at home and say
well done now we're going to tax you so
if you look at those you might have a
bit more money circulating around and in
their back pocket it's not
obvious you want to take it and then
create you know a sense that if you do
well
in the age of kovid you're then going to
be tax on it but i
i would add and liam touched upon this a
third way and that is going for economic
growth
i think if i were the chancellor one of
the things that would deeply concern me
are all these comparisons to world war
ii
one of the reasons the economy jumped
back so quickly and we were able
to get spending under control is because
economic growth was very good now
obviously this year we're looking at a a
huge contraction we had a
20 contraction in the second quarter uh
the economy is has
fallen drastically this year but let's
look at the past decade
growth was on average roughly 1.8
percent i believe it has not been
a pro-growth decade so if the chancellor
wants to grow his way
out of this public spending problem uh
he's going to have to go for a lot of
supply-side reform some of which are
going to be politically difficult it's
great to see
that they're already tackling the
planning system that should
hopefully give britain a real boost when
that gets underway but they're going to
have to do more i suppose i would just
end by
going back to a question that you asked
earlier katie about um
corbinism and and does this justify it i
suppose in a way
i still think there are major
differences you won't find an economist
you'll struggle to anyway
on the left or the right who would argue
that during a pandemic when you have to
hibernate the economy that is
not the time to spend money virtually
everybody agrees that is the time
to spend a lot of money i think the
difference is that
well both parties in the 2019 election
were looking at
spending more than than was within their
means
the conservatives were going to
overspend by tens of billions and the
labor party was going to overspend in
supposedly the good times by hundreds
of billions of pounds uh no no plan to
to get their house in order in the good
times
so i think the real criticism of the
conservative party is where has
that fundamental philosophy gone that
you have to make sure that the books are
in order
when when times are good because when
times get bad when you have a pandemic
or something else horrible that happens
that's when you need to spend the money
and again if i were the chancellor i
would be thinking about this new pledge
to free school meals over the summer
we're told that's a coveted policy but i
suspect that won't go away next year
the government's going to have to fund
that in day-to-day spending
quite a lot of measures that have come
in in the name of kovit i think will
last
and the chancellor is going to have to
be very strict
unless he wants to fall into some
kind of corbinous thinking that that
money
really has to be accounted for that
day-to-day spending and
theoretically the better times it's hard
to think of a good time at the moment in
the future but better
times uh can be funded by the magic
money tree
brilliant thanks kate and perry to sleep
we want to slightly uh
adding to the pessimism perhaps uh
interesting you mentioned planning
reforms and supply side because
speaking to tory mps today i think that
in itself
is going to be a battle to even get
through so um
very interesting times ahead and i'm
sure we'll be having more discussions
like this
in the coming months and thank you to
kate thank you to liam thank you frasier
for joining us today and thank you for
watching
do join us tomorrow for the final day of
the alternative conference time
clearly flies when you're having fun um
thanks for i'm now going to exit this
conversation
and end the chat